so Africa and waifu you are mother and
daughter yes where are you guys from
from Stockton California Stockton how
old are you I'm 27 you're 27 yeah okay
so you're not a kid
nah but you guys have separate only fans
accounts yes you're both only fans sex
workers yeah technically she technically
I'm different I'm different yeah I'm
different So like um I do censored
content so actually this is a lot this
is this is showing too much I was going
to come here with my censor bar yeah
it's just a matter of time though before
you start showing more and more oh no no
no we're trying to keep it
gold no really really yeah good mhm and
Mom you've been doing this for how long
since uh since I was 27 so very very
long long long couple years ago I'm
googleable
yeah and this is a a career that came
came about because you were just looking
for a new hustle or no this is a career
that came about because I had a
baby first I was just dancing and and
stuff but then um you know how like you
can kind of couch Sur couch surf you
can't do that with a baby so then I
upped my
game Into the industry so you are
shooting yes I'm shooting by myself
right now sexual content though yes yes
how do you you feel about that wifeu
daughter I mean to me it's it's whatever
because like it's like mom's job as
mom's job cuz Mom is Mom and she kind of
made it easy to like see work as work
and then like home life as home life so
it never really bled into each other did
she encourage you to do the no
absolutely not I was freaked out no like
my first thing that I wanted to do was
uh I wanted to be a computer tech and
then I realized that I didn't want to be
a computer tech I wanted to to be a web
um a web developer so websites cuz I
started doing coding you know when
Myspace was a thing I was doing coding
and I was making those layouts from
scratch and I was like oo I like this so
yeah um but I didn't go into that
because uh when I got out of high school
IT Tech closed down there weren't really
any Tech schools around my area so I was
just kind of like well now I'm kind of
floating about trying to figure things
out and I don't know I don't know so
yeah but we were kind of she got freaked
out she thought we were really I mean
really in a bad way so she thought let
me try myself but she um freaked me out
cuz I thought she was really going to
try and she dabbled but did not like it
yeah so she knows she's not going to
yeah she did not like so she does just
censored stuff I found that by accident
though but I told her when she was
little I told her that um you know I I
prepared her because I figured some
people would notice me and so I told her
that you know you know it's better
coming from your mom than you know and I
do you get notice on the street
yes yes and then even at her school
sometimes I would take her to school and
then you would hear somebody go Africa
Africa and I would just ignore like I
don't know who you talking about so only
fans income is your only s source of
income right now yes yeah
yes and it's something that works for
you um it could work better no it's not
really working very but it's because I
have anxiety and um I'm shy as well so
it's
weird so I I I have I have these moments
where I'm just like fine I'm content
content content and then then it's like
I'm I'm hiding but the reality of only
fans being on only fans I've heard
is you need to interact with your
audience subscribers hard yeah tell me
about that it's like they're I'm not
used to that because when like a long
long time ago before all the internet
stuff they you just show up to set and
they handled all of that the all the
advertising and and stuff like that
doing porn before this yes I was doing
porn for like she was
one 1996 yeah 1997 yeah yeah so she so
it was really the companies would handle
all this stuff but now you got to Market
yourself and you go to You're the porn
company yeah yeah you're doing it all
yeah but you make all the money yeah
yeah only fans take us takes a
percentage but yeah but the rest of it
is all yours yeah until taxes come
around right welcome to the United
States whole different
tax who makes more money Mom oh yeah
definitely cuz she's selling it yeah I'm
I'm like over here in my own little
world I got my own little community so
yeah her community there's a community
okay so you know how you explain it you
know how like it's so like on Jerry
Springer you know when the girls get
their Jerry Beads right and that big old
centor bar pops up that's what I do
except I don't get naked I don't do
anything explicit I don't DD myself on
camera how long have you been on um I've
been on since 20121 like officially cuz
I was doing like feet for a while
everyone jumped on the feet bag
and I tried that I was
not I think there's like a specific type
of girl that they want everybody she
Wasing a lot cuz everybody thought well
no not just that in my advertising stuff
cuz I've been doing graphic design and
stuff since I was little so you know
it's it's kind of like I already had
that down but um no I wasn't making
anything doing feet found the censored
content on accident somebody told me
about a bunch of subreddits that I could
post in for feet stuff and then among
those subreddits was this thing called
censored for Betas and I was like nah
what is that and so I I went I clicked
on it and it's just a bunch of porn that
is intentionally censored for the denial
aspect because they think they're you're
they're too you're they want to they
want to be like beneath you so it goes
into the whole Dom area not good enough
to see you yeah these Kinks and fetishes
are just interesting and unusual yeah I
know so that like to be
frustrated yeah yeah and right now
October's going on so you know that's
that's also a thing that's happening
that goes into there I'm doing that
October is when guys they have their
chassity cages and they will stay locked
for all of October or they won't have
any wow no they won't jerk off all of
October just learned that yeah that's a
thing October yeah that's going to hurt
mom's income right no no probably not no
there's not too many people that want to
loed up in a cage like haha here's some
teasing pictures like so mom works in
porn how do you feel about that it's
it's fine it's fine yeah it hasn't
really like I haven't really felt any
type of way about it for me do you
remember anything that I told you when
you were little I like how how is it
this easy cuz uh I remember like if
anybody tells you anything it's like
they're just coming for you because your
mom cares about to
like like your mom would do so much for
you and these other kids it's just like
their mom have has a regular job and
they don't even see their parents I did
say that I was like so you spent a lot
of time with your I spent a lot of time
with so I got hurt all day I got to
homeschooler sometimes yeah we got to
homeschool or like if I had trouble your
mom's a good mom oh yeah oh yeah way
more involved than I think any
stereotypical parent and I feel like
that's something a lot of people
wouldn't think she got bullied sometimes
because of they tried because of
her I I hate for my my channel to become
like an endorsment for only fans but
tell me Africa the the positives and the
negatives of being un only fans okay
since I am introverted the negatives
would be um actually not that I don't
love my fans I do but I'm not used to it
seems like they're right there in my
face and they're not right there in my
face it's just letter
and numbers but it just feels like
they're right there and and that but
there's nobody in the room it's just you
but yeah it's just me but you feel you
feel the presence of all these yes guys
yes even with this and then we have to
do Skype too and that makes it even more
like you're in my face like this you you
have to do like live stuff yeah Skypes
you have to do that yeah that's a part
of that's a part of um you know income
so
so if they ask for a Skype they get a
Skype there a lot of women that are
doing this I think now yeah what do you
think what do you make of that just that
that so many women are doing only fans
now I think that selling their ass on
the internet yeah yeah I think we we
should actually just legalize the the
harder stuff so we can well I mean only
fans is legal yeah the legal the only
fans is legal but you know sometimes you
you know I think they should Legalize It
All The Way prostitution prostitution
should be legalized if you're not like
the best legalize it because it seems
like everybody's getting more open to
sex anyway they're being more open about
liking it and more open about um being
in it or or having or having found that
they needed to do this to supplement
their income or something everybody at
first these same people were probably
like ew I would never do that I would
never do pandemic
came it changed it all right yeah
yeah now what won't you
do so everybody seems like they're more
open with it we should just be open with
all of it yeah sex is such
a polarizing charged thing in in our
society yeah you're taking what is
probably for a lot of females their main
way to make money yes for a lot of girls
yes and nobody wants to be and you
you're making it illegal it's bad we all
deem it is bad yeah and every everybody
does it even police officers so they
need to
stop they need to
stop yeah then all the guys are watching
it yeah you're right yeah so the guys
love to watch it but they want to
demonize you at the same time in public
but well I mean so only fans is legal
but but the prostitution the all the
other stuff yeah yeah you should
legalize all of it it's a complicated
world we live in yes it is very very
much so do you want to do other things
with your life when you were younger uh
yeah what do you want to
do well everybody thought I was going to
sing or be a comedian or something or an
actress they thought that so I thought
that right along with them or have a
daycare or you know then later as she
got older I wanted a
spa but but all of those jobs would
require a lot of time and time away from
home yeah if it it was my spa she would
be with me
she she went me the yoga class how much
time do you spend working on your only
fans um every day yeah it's a little bit
every day yeah that's how you do it but
I I need to do a little
more I'm fine until I'm fine until I
have a moment where my anxiety starts
going way way up then it's like where is
she and wifeu so your only fans is is
basically what what it's basically
like how would I even describe it it's
definitely like in the domination
category I don't know if you guys know
what like dominatrixes are but it's like
online domination but I'm trying to make
it less in-your-face domination and more
subtle things because I was like a hard
Dom for a really long time so there is a
sexual it there's like it's sex charged
it's sexually charged for sure but it's
not like sex like the most I'll do is
like a micro keini and like penis
ratings oh yeah that too I forgot about
those sometimes people buy them what is
that when you uh sometimes people ask
for like a like a dick rating and like
they'll pay you to they'll send you a
picture of it and you have to rate it
usually the girls will have like they'll
rate it nice or something or'll be like
oh it's so big or whatever but my job as
the Dom is to be like oh it's so tiny it
can't do anything blah blah blah blah so
it's like it's supposed to be like
culating that goes into the SP category
and small penous
humiliation
so it's definitely well it's so yeah
it's definitely not your
stereotypical only fans stuff did you
think you mom doing only fans is what
kind of opened the door for you to do it
um no I think it was like did you have
yours first I don't know honestly I
think I did I think I had mine first oh
so you had it first yeah I made one I
just assumed that mom had it and then
you no actually you know I didn't know
what only fans okay so I went out of
business for a while I who makes more
money she is oh yeah oh yeah I went I
was doing regular stuff like you know
customer service and all this other
stuff and then when I came back people
were saying you should get an only fans
and I was like I didn't know what that
was and I was like oh I don't
know cuz I was just used to going to
Studios and stuff I was like oh I don't
know what that is but you know she's
like let's work on my website like she's
kind of like my datinger so she was like
oh you need a you need a website you
need a this you needed that so then I
then I learned more about it yeah so I
was like oh man I was snubbing my nose
up to only to only fans all this time
and that was crazy and wife you you are
you help Mom with her yeah I have to
sometimes yeah so what is it like to be
looking at Mom's like uh I don't go in
and watch anything I don't go in there
and watch anything
um I'll just see like what her most
current post is sometimes and I'll be
like okay do she post did she not is it
and sometimes I'll scan messages like I
won't open them cuz I don't want to take
too much from her CU I feel like I don't
want to overstep that's my mom like but
I'll just see if there's anything in
there that maybe she needs to pay
attention to or I'll throw suggestions
out like I made um like a Skype menu for
her or something that she can schedule
out um lately I've been like do Ander
yeah I've been on the hunt for like
industry stuff for her like uh like Big
Industry stuff for her so um I'll go in
and try and find people's emails and try
and find contacts and things so that way
we can like reach out to bigger Studios
do iner so yeah I do I I do a lot of
things I do a lot of
things you guys are an interesting team
yes yes I remember one time we were like
really struggling but some for some
reason um this was before I went back
into business um people just kind of
would come up to us and give us money
and she's like Mom you need to get on
the corner and just smile just
smile cuz I'll be like hi they love her
for in my hand because when we were
working regular jobs like um one of our
jobs that we were together was Target
like they would just wait in her line
because she's like awesome all in the
line anytime she scans anything and they
don't care like how long a line is they
just love her personality she'll just
they'll just wait in her line like we
had people filling out the customer
surveys like do you see your
attractiveness your sexuality as a way
to make money yes it's going to be hard
to change that
yeah it wouldn't be so hard if um if you
if they paid minimum wage uh if minimum
wage was realistic it wouldn't be so
hard it's very hard to make a living now
yeah yep yeah yep that's another reason
why people go here is because you got
stuff that you want to do in life and if
you just stay at the 9 to-5 they say oh
you can advance yeah
right yeah right so I think I worked
maybe like three or four jobs for real
ones and I just was like I'm out of here
bro like you're making more money now um
I feel like you know what it's building
I'm still making a little Community um
like I run a subreddit that has like
25,000 members that just are dedicated
to censored stuff and I want to grow it
so I'm hoping to make more but um what
do you charge a month for your only fans
right now it's at 5.99 it's definitely
gonna go up at some point what is Mom's
mine is only 12 cuz I didn't
know I didn't know mine is only like 12
aash I didn't know cuz when when I first
started it was like a whole bunch of
people with $5 only fans and a whole
bunch of $5 only fans so I was like I'll
just be $112 then but I wish I could be
30 I should have started at 50 but I
have a website two and that is 30
yeah stretch it out stretch it out I get
Siff down here yeah not not that kind of
stuff huh um all right you guys thank
you so much for uh enlightening us about
your only fans yay and uh what are you
going to do while you're in La um try
and get home yeah we we yeah we didn't
have a plan did we have a plan we didn't
have a plan we were coming we just like
make sure we're here yep Y and then we
you we're here for you yep we are here
we got your back yep you're string
daughter on only fans
yay all right you guys thank you very
much so so your only fans is Africa sex
that's my only fans and it's spelled
with three
X's mine is at beta safe Wu um it should
be all one word oh beta safe
wuvp is my paid one I have a freed one
but that's free so okay we figure this
out yeah y thank you thank
you